[Alkış]
Merhabalar
hoş geldiniz
ne eğittinize geldiniz ya harika
gözüküyorsunuz gerçekten
[Alkış]
Şimdi benim konum iyilik frekansı 3.6.5
çok havalı olduğunun farkındayım sanki
yazılım mühendisiyim bir şeyler yazdım
Birazdan da bir şey anlatacağım gibi
gözüküyor bir şey anlatacağım doğru
yazılım mühendisi falan değilim ama bir
frekans keşfettim
acayip
Bu benim 0 noktam için
bu 0 noktasını yaklaşık 13 yaşında
keşfettim
13 yaşlarında
Kitap okudum kitabın adı
hanene ay doğacak
yazar Şebnem işi güzel
[Müzik]
Can yayınevinde yani
kitabı okuduktan sonra ben de acayip bir
etki bıraktı yazarla dedim mutlaka Ne
yapıp ne edip tanışmam lazım
hemen kitabın arkasını çevirdim Can
Yayınları telefon numarası var tık tık
tık tık tık tık değil arkadaşlar cırır
cırt biliyor musunuz siz onu
Hani Dokunmatik telefonların olmadığı
dönemde böyle çevirmeli telefonların
olduğu dönemde
Can yayınlarını aradım ve dedim ki
Merhaba ben Nihan Şebnem abla ile
görüşebilir miyim Tabi o yıllarda bu
tarz iletişimler çok moda değil yani
Özellikle bir çocuğun bir yayın evini
araması oradan bir yazarla görüşme
talebi almadıklarından olsa gerek
telefon genelde
diye kapatarak ilerledi
bu Yaklaşık 3 ay sürdü sizleri görememek
Çok Zormuş Bu arada biraz öne geleceğim
Ben her gün okuldan geldikten sonra Can
yayınevini aradım
Şebnem içi güzel ile görüşmek istedim
Her telefon kapatışı genelde benzer
senaryolarla oldu
Neyse ki günler Günler haftalar
haftaları değiştirdi bir gün artık bir
canlı yayınlarında çalışan görevli dedi
ki seni dedi tek bir şartla dedi Şebnem
Hanım da dedi görüştüreceğim
bir daha burayı arama
ve bana o dönem için şey geldi böyle
mantıklı bir şey geldi yani iyi bir
sözleşme bir anlaşma yaptık gibi geldi
Kabul ettim söz verdim bir daha aramamak
için şimdi
mezunum ikinci perdesi başladı daha
sıkıntılı mevzudan annemin haberi yok
Dolayısıyla ben okuldan her gün eve
geliyorum ve şey diyorum
Anne beni arayan oldu mu
olmadı
13 yaşındayım ya Dolayısıyla Hani
ergenlik ve hormonlarla ilgili bir
sorunum olduğunu düşünüyor birinden
hoşlandığımı Dolayısıyla ondan telefon
beklediğimi düşünüyor
benim kafam bambaşka bir yerde mutlaka
Nar yapıp nedir Şebnem işi güzel ile
tanışmam lazım Her gün geliyorum aynı
şey Bir de o dönemde iletişim böyle
değil yani evet telefon var çevirmeli
Bu arada sol tarafta 13 yaş Halim
bilmiyorum benziyor mu
evrim geçirmiş Halim yıl 93 şimdi
kapının arkasında göremediğiniz kısımda
şuna benzer bir telefon var
alttaki numara Can yayınlarına ait Yani
yayın evinin frekansı diyebiliriz biz
buna
her tuşu çevirmek yaklaşık 6 saniye
falan sürüyor ben bunu her gün yapıyorum
yani böyle hani bir numarayı bir defa
çevirmem böyle ve bir dakikamı falan
oluyor
dedi ki böyle Annem artık en sonunda şey
dedi bir gün
beklediğim telefon geldi
dedi saatte de akşam 7'de seni Şebnem
işi güzel arayacak
tım Yani bunu Saat 4 sıralarında falan
söylüyordu 3 saat o kapının arkasında ki
telefonun orada Ford mantoya oturarak
bekledim aramasını beni
çok kıymetli Çünkü bizim dönemimizdeki
iletişim telefonla
en fazla bilgiyi ansiklopedyeden
öğreniyoruz
Bence
iyi iletişimlerden bir tanesi o dönemin
mektubu Hani diyeceksiniz ki konuşmak da
bir iletişim bizim zamanımızda konuşmak
öyle İyi bir iletişim tekniği değildi
özellikle böyle ergenlik dönemindeysen
biz böyle iletişimimizi ve içimize
içimize Konuşurduk yani Ebeveynler
öğretmenlerimiz eğitmenlerimiz
konuşurduk biz Duygu düşüncelerimizi
içimize söylerdik çok böyle dıştan
duymaya hazır değildi o dönemin
Türkiye'si
Ondan sonra
Şebnem Hanım aradı uzun bir telefon
konuşması yaptık dedi ki senin dedi
soruların bitmez merakım da bende de en
iyi sığınan dedi adresini vereyim
seninle dedi mektup arkadaşı olalım
benim için mükemmel bir haber Tabii ilk
mektup arkadaşım bir yazar oldu şimdi
merak ettiğim konu şu onunla ilgili
dergilerde röportajlar okuyorum diyorlar
ki 1993 Yunus Nadi Öykü ödülünü kazandı
Şebnem işe güzel hem ödüllü hem sansürlü
Nasıl ya Yani şimdi Biz iyi bir şeyler
yaptığımızda önce ödüllendirip sonra
cezalandırılıyor muyuz
kafam karışmaya başladı O noktada
Çünkü bu böyle gitmez
ve hemen işe koyuldum şimdi bu benim
başlangıç noktam Çünkü ilk defa
farkındalığım yüksek
planladım hedefledim vazgeçmedim ve
ulaştım Demek ki dedim hayatta birçok
şeye ulaşabilirim ve tanımadığım
insanlar benim hayatımda o kadar büyük
bir Ufuk Açtı ki ondan sonra 0
noktasından
3.6.5 noktasına bir köprü kurdum bu
köprü yani o arayı anlatmayacağım size
ama o kadar güçlü
o kadar kuvvetli şeffaf dürüst oldu ki
bundan 6 sene önce
hayalimi gerçekleştirmeme sebep oldu
tamam arasının çok uzun olduğunu
farkındayım bambaşka Hikayeler var
Aralarda
Dedim ki rakamların bir frekansı var
sürekli
bir titreşim
bir gün yine böyle düşünüyorum
ya fazla düşünmekten dolayı oluyor Yani
çünkü her şeye takıyorum kafayı ben
kimim neden dünyaya geldim Bu Dünya
nereye gidiyor nereden geliyor her şey
çok kötü kaotik bir durum vesaire falan
var ortada gün geçtikçe de hiç iyi bir
haber almıyorum bundan 5-6 sene
öncesinde de yine durumu benzer
insanlar birbirinden o kadar çok
uzaklaştı ki
dedim ki
dünyayı değiştiremem Yani şimdilik Ama
başka şeyleri değiştirebilirim Mesela
dedim yaşadığım şehir Aydın
Aa bu arada Şebnem Hanım'ın mektuplaştı
da mektuplaşmaya başladıktan sonra her
çıkan kitabın bana imzalı olarak
Göndermeye devam etti Onu sizinle
paylaşmayı unuttum
insanların birbirinden uzaklaşmasını
fark ettikten sonra da Aydın'da dedim
kolları sıvayalım
insanları birbirine yaklaştırayım daha
çok yardımlaşma olsun daha çok katkı
olsun daha çok faydalı işler yapalım
peki dedim neden bu kadar Ayrıyız yani
bu kadar bir toplum olup neden bu kadar
ayrıştık ortak bir amaç
çerçevesinde buluşamaz mıyız yani Tabii
ki de buluşabilirdik sorunu tespit
edelim sonrasında çözmek çok basit değil
mi peki insanların arasındaki iletişim
bozukluğunun sebebi ne neden
birbirlerine güvenmiyorlar
neden yardım etmek bizim gözümüzde o
kadar zor
vakit ayıramamak
bütçesel olarak uygun olamamak yani
Çünkü her şey paraya bağlanıyor bir
şekilde
bu sorunların çözüm yollarını aradıktan
sonra dedim ki Tamam ben bir şey buldum
bunu farklı yapacağım
365 gün
3.6.5 versiyonu öyle dünyaya geldi Çünkü
bunun sürekli olması lazım yani bu
frekansı sürekli olarak yaymam
gerektiğini fark ettim bir gün değil
yani yılda iki defa Ramazan Bayramı
Kurban Bayramı'nda değil iyilik
biliyorsunuz daha yeni geçtik Ramazan
Bayramını o Ramazan sürecini mutlaka ki
görmüşsünüzdür daha fazla iyilik
yapıldığına daha hassas konuşmalar
yapıldığını işte İftar yemeklerini
mesela onu da çok anlayamıyorum niye
kendi kendimize iftar yemeği yiyoruz
Çünkü amaç şey ya hani daha çok ihtiyaç
sahibine ulaşabilmek onlarla daha fazla
şey paylaşabilmek yani şimdi çok lüks
bir restorana gidip kendi kendimize
iftar yapmamızı ben çok
anlamlandıramıyorum
dedim ki Tamam bunları sen bir toparla
bir ilke olması lazım
şöyle bir ilke içinde Güven olacak
dürüstlük Olacak şeffaflık Olacak
ve Bence son dönemde birazcık
unuttuğumuz Nezaket olacak
ben çok hassas bir konu
5 yıl içerisinde
2000'den fazla aileye bir tek kuruş
maddi yardım almadan ihtiyaç sahibi
ailelere ulaştık
Yani bu para kısmını dışarı çıkardıktan
sonra hani olmuyordu Hani yapılmıyordu
hani kimsenin vakti yoktu buna
dedim ki frekans yayılmaya başlıyor o
titreşim var insanlar heyecanlanmaya
başlıyorlar Çünkü artık iyilik yapmanın
ne kadar farklı Yolları olduğunu
keşfettiler
değişim güzel tarafı Böyle kafalarda hep
şey oluyordu Hani yardım ederim ama
nereye gidiyor bilmiyorum Bazen bilmemek
İyi de geliyor insana herhalde dedim
Benden çıktı artık hani diğer tarafın
günahı boynuna Hemen bak sattı ki Günaha
da sattık arada kaydırdık Evet öbür
tarafa dedim ki Herkesin günahı kendine
kalsın bir tespit ettireyim Dolayısıyla
yardıma ihtiyacı olanlar yardım etmek
isteğini isterlerse buluşturuyorum
Eğer buluşmak istemezlerse
teknolojiden Yardım alarak Bunlar
fotoğraflanıyor videolanıyor ve
Eğer yardım gerçekten nereye gittiğini
görmek isterlerse kendilerine
ulaştırılıyor sosyal medya aracılığıyla
Şimdi bunlar iyi güzel hoş şeyler
Fakat unuttuğumuzda çok kıymetli bir şey
daha var yardımı yapma Şeklimiz yani
burada
iyilik yapmak Birine bir şey bırakıp
gitmek değil örnek veriyorum
bir tane kız çocuğumuz var
onun bota ihtiyacı var
Siz de aldığınız botu verdiniz
Yani sizden çıktı olay artık
365 gün iyiliğin Köprüsü giriyor
Ben de diyorum ki size
6 yaşında Bakın bu kız
ve botunuz aldığınız bot Ayağında
kıymeti çok güzel bir şey keşke vakit
olduğu zamanlar oluyor tabii ama
kendilerinin Birebir Alışveriş yapması
kendilerinin bizlerle gidip ailelere
ulaşması o ayakkabıyı birisi zat
kendilerinin giydirmesi daha müthiş bir
frekans açıyor
yani
Anlatılmaz yaşanır duygular içerisinden
bir tanesi bu
Kargo Firması değiliz Eğer bir iyiliği
yapacaksanız gerçekten de ortaya çok
önemli başka bir konu daha çıkıyor
Nezaket
Biz ailelere ulaşırken
eşyalar eşya teslim edeceğiz Mesela
örnek vereyim şey yapıyoruz Hani Buyurun
İşte bu gıda koliniz bu işte çocuğunuzun
ayakkabısı montu İşte bu başka bir
ihtiyacınız demiyoruz bizzat zaten daha
öncesinden iletişim kurduğumuz için
kapılarını çalıyoruz
sofralarına oturuyoruz dertlerini
dinliyoruz
çözüm bulabiliyorsak Eğer derslerine
çözüm oluyoruz bulamıyorsak da çözüm
olabileceğini düşündüğümüz kanalların
yollarını açıyoruz
şey demek çok kolay hani artık teknoloji
çok gelişti Evet yani kendi
ihtiyaçlarını kendileri görebilirler
bizim gibi yaşamıyorlar
yaşamalarına izin verilmiyor Bu gerçeği
görmezden gelmek En kolayı Ama artık
biliyorsanız
farkındaysanız olmamış gibi
davranamazsınız biz davranamadık Çünkü
Aydın'da halen
Atça şurası değil mi Çok yakın belki
misafirler şehir dışından gelen
Misafirlerimiz konum olarak
bilemeyebilirler Ama yaklaşık bir 25-30
kilometre var mıdır
çileğin Merkezi değil mi önünde kocaman
çilek resimleri falan var Çok güzel bir
zamanda mevsimde meyvesini yiyoruz hiç
Çilek yememiş çileği görmemiş çocuklarla
tanıştık 365 günü Her yıl doğum gününde
çocuklara ve pasta götürüyoruz beraber
kesiyoruz Çünkü birçoğu doğum gününü
kutlamıyor yani doğum günü nasıl
kutlanır bilmiyor Bir tane
iki kardeş ikizler onların evine misafir
ettik bundan 4 yıl önce
yani onlara çilekli pasta Denk geldiniz
çeşit çeşit pastaları almıştık o gün
için
açtık işte mutfakta hazırlıyoruz Bu
arada hani şey gibi değil bakım step
üste pasta getirdik kesildim işte
tabakları bildiğiniz bu mutfaklarına
giriyoruz o pastaları kesiyoruz
tabakları koyuyoruz çayımızı demliyoruz
kutuyu açtıktan sonra çocuklar şoka
girdi
dedi ki abla dedi de gerçek çilek mi
Çünkü o zamana kadar televizyonda ya da
boyama kitabında
temas etmiş görmüş
Evet dedim gerçek çilek dedi yiyebilir
miyim
hemen pastaya daldık Biz çilekleri
çikolataları kremaları yedik yüzümüze
gözümüze de bulaştırdık çok eğlendik
yani bu
kentin Gerçeği çok uzaklara gitmeyelim
burada yaşamıyor
ama
Haziranda altıncı yılımız
ekibimiz
kaç kişidir 365 günün çalışma ekibi
Tahmin var mı
10 kişiyiz arkadaşlar
Hani binlerce aile binlerce çocuk Sokak
hayvanı
temas ettiğimiz her canlıya güzel bir
şeyler yapmak için toplam 10 kişiyiz
dönem dönem 5'e iniyoruz 15'e çıkıyoruz
Çünkü gönüllük esasına göre çalıştığımız
için
kalan sağlar bizim dedik yola devam
ediyoruz
güzellik şurada bulaşıcı
yani
ürkütücü gibi değil ama çok güzel
bulaşıcı artık bundan sonra bir aileyle
bir çocukla ihtiyaç sahibi biriyle temas
ettiğinizde yardım etmemek kafanızı
çevirip gidemiyorsunuz arkanıza
Bence
müthiş bir şey
bu yolculuk çok uzun ben bu 365 gün
detayını böyle saatlerce falan
anlatıyorum bugün bana ayrılan Vakit
kısa çok sevdiğim bir arkadaşım var
kulakları çınlasın Harun ökek
[Müzik]
koltukta oturdukları bir sahneymiş Barış
Manço kalkıyor
bir adım öne çıkıyor
Hanımefendi ben diyor 42 numara ayakkabı
giyiyorum
Yani bu yeryüzünde
42 numaralık yer kaplıyorum e müsaade
edin de onun hakkını vereyim
ben de
bu dünyaya geldiysem
ve
bu kadar yer kaplıyorsam
bunun hakkını vermem gerekiyor Bunu
yapmamın en temel sebebi bu kadar
durmadan
yorulmadan hiç vazgeçmeden yapmanın tek
sebebi Mustafa Kemal Atatürk ve onunla
yürüyen herkes için yapıyorum herkesin
boynunun borcunu ödeme şekli farklı
olabilir ama benim ödeme şeklim yılmadan
vazgeçmeden her daim çizdiğim o yolda
yürümek oldu
[Alkış]
teşekkür ederim